some ways we are in a good age of
science I mean I don't I think actually
many respects science science is doing
well right now you know in terms of but
I think there's just a general fear that
that won't continue that people won't
take it seriously that if there are
budget cuts that's where it will happen
I think it's really important that we
recognize the really important role
science has played not just people doing
science but people being trained as
scientists a lot of people who have gone
out and done important things have for
trained a scientist I'm always surprised
whatever you people know they tell me
they tell me that they were actually a
lot of people who read my book for
example or you know will be in different
fields in and there'll be people who
aren't doing anything life science now
but they were trained as scientists and
I think we really have to appreciate how
critical that is I think this sort of
and how important basic research is not
just applied research but people really
working on fundamental problems being
allowed to think about that and how
basic research has had these broad
ranging implications in the future that
we didn't anticipate so just I think a
general recognition of the role that
science has played it would be really
important
you